My parodid gland is swallowing the radiologist told me to use a warm compress on it.
Now a college is told me to go to an ENT to see if it needs to be drained.
What do you think?
I have my Onyx research site as I'm parodid tablets, but it's still difficult to do pills
because I rely on a feeding tube and crushing them tends to jam that up.
So this person got radiation therapy, I believe.
That's what they're talking about here with the parodid gland being swallowing.
I don't know why they told you to do a warm compress.
The typically the thing with swallowing you do ice, maybe they're trying to get it to
drain.
You can do cold for five minutes, then warm for five minutes, cold for five minutes, warm
for five minutes.
You can try that to get a pumpy to action through it.
That might help.
I would try both warm and ice.
I would see which one tends to work better for you.
Sometimes heat works better for people and gets things going.
Sometimes that just causes more swelling.
So you're just going to have to try those things.
Can have ice handy to do it.
The site as I've parodid will just help rebuild the parodid gland.
It's not going to really help get rid of any swelling in there.
And he's concerned if there is a pocket of swelling that needs that could be drained.
That's a possibility, but I haven't really heard that I would go.
I would use the ice and heat first and see if you can get things moving.